speaking of a little too big the second
story is this really really bizarre
story uh that started it kicked off last
week when tucker carlson
accused the nsa of spying on him because
uh
information was leaked that he said
could only have been leaked from
his private email we've got a little
more on that
last week last monday we told you that
the biden administration's largest
intelligence gathering agency the nsa
had been reading my private emails even
saying that out loud is weird it's one
of those segments we never thought we
would do
ever but the country has changed that
much that fast and honestly the whole
thing was kind of shocking
the government was spying on us come on
it seemed crazy
but it's true and no one in washington
appeared to be shocked in the slightest
in fact the usual shills right after our
segment had a ready explanation for it
either it never happened at all they
said just a cable news show lying for
ratings
or there must have been a good reason it
happened and they began
furiously making excuses for the nsa did
it a powerful heavily politicized spy
agency surveilling journalists who've
been critical of the regime
no problem it's perfectly normal just
don't call it spying
but it's not normal at all it is third
world
and as we told you repeatedly it did
happen now that has been confirmed
all right so just to clarify tucker had
reached out to kremlin contacts about
getting an interview with putin
tucker is a journalist he interviews
people that's what they do
uh walter it seems like most of media is
just like yeah big damn whoop he
shouldn't have reached out or
or he's a russian operative i mean just
the usual nonsense
that we've gotten you know over the last
four or five years
yeah well okay here's the thing about
this story
um the nsa loves it the nsa
despite the sometimes seeming like the
bad guy
loves the message that yep
we can do anything to anyone at any time
and we don't have to be candid about it
they let tucker
they let tucker make the accusation they
then let him be
called a liar they then didn't interfere
when it turns out to be true
and you know we see that the thing he
was being spied for
was trying to get an interview with one
of the other
maybe two world leaders who are run a
great nuclear power
i mean what is what is more legitimate
journalism
than trying to interview you know putin
they make it sound as though he was
doing a dead drop in force marcy park
you know
trying to uh pass microfilm my god
he was trying to get an interview with a
world leader yeah
you know what is totally flabbergasting
about all this i have never seen in
unison so many
certified blue check marks on twitter
mainstream media
run to the defense of the nsa i don't
want to have these conspiratorial
thoughts like
they must the media must be working with
intelligence
it's either that or their absolute
ignorance
and have totally forgotten about the
largest illegal
domestic surveillance program that the
nsa was carrying out
a few years ago a decade ago and they
pretend now that that could never happen
again and
certainly if it does happen they've made
a carve out for fox news and tucker
carlson
i i've never seen such willful blindness
or deliberate misinformation
from the mainstream media all running
cover for the nsa given the nsa's
history but viva
let's not forget who who was the guy
that was in charge of the nsa when he
was under oath and they asked him if
we're spying on americans and he said
not wittingly as he was scratching the
top of his head which is a tip off from
seinfeld
who is the guy who was that does anyone
he works for cnn now yeah i mean he
works for cnn
this is not a conspiracy no one's hiding
it that's why i say they loves it
the nsa loves having its former director
on cnn
it loves taking the largest
cable news personality in the world and
making him
sit in the hot seat while it you know
doesn't
you know that's for me to know and you
to find out we're the nsa
carlin is that the broad is that like
the real stamp on this thing right there
that they can just do it in front of us
there's nothing tucker can do there's
nothing the rest of us can do and as
viva says
we can also just have a bunch of uh blue
check journalists
that uh basically applaud them for it
well i mean listen walter has just
scared the heck out of me because i'm
100 sure he's correct that the nsa is
loving this entire thing and i think it
just goes so it says so much about
how far the divisions in this world have
gone where you know people who maybe 10
years ago would have been completely
against any of this nonsense so now like
well it's okay as long as it's directed
by political opponents
like people have forgotten what the
slippery slope is and what it means if
they can do it to your political
opponents that means they can do it to
you
right the lefties were pretty upset when
snowden was leaking all of the stuff
about what the government was doing
somehow they care a little bit less
when it's tucker